[Music]
you could give me the best ingredients
in the world you could then give
the best chef in the world seed and b
level versions of all that and it's not
even gonna be close to what's more
delicious
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
podcast station what is good uh it is me
gary vaynerchuk
uh really excited because we just don't
really do interviews these days
and uh i was doing something with uh
my my 137 platform and
we were doing a card talk event with
ebay and
channing was on the show and i was like
you know what you got to get on my
podcast
you know i i i i really like this dude i
think you know
a i'm a knicks fan so i got to really
enjoy
the early part of his career and then
more importantly it's been an incredible
world i live in now where you know the
entrepreneur
and entrepreneurship has become
something that is like a thing
similar to an athlete or
a rapper and and that's amazing because
i'm watching
i mean how old are you 38 just turned 38
on monday
happy birthday so channing is 38 years
old he's a ridiculously young dude
that's how i see it that's how i live it
and
what i know is that 30 years ago the 38
year old former basketball player
is is searching right is searching you
know if
if he doesn't go into coaching or front
office
a lot of those men because i've talked
to a lot of 60 70 80 year old athletes
really struggled with the post
kind of like emotional like transition
of like you are focused on one thing
your whole life
and then the world and your body tells
you it's a wrap
yet you're young and watching business
become a new place for these alpha
competitive
curious innovative creative dudes
and ladies um has been amazing for me to
watch because i'm such a sports fan and
so
i not only like channing because he's
got nick blood
but i like him because i've been
watching him from afar
from the beginning of him being
thoughtful in my opinion on social
and so it's been fun to watch him evolve
get himself into things
and i thought it'd be fun to have a
conversation talk a little basketball
talk a little business
talk a little bit about whatever he
wants so channing why don't you take the
floor
and do a little three to four minute
manifesto of who you are what you're
about what you're into and then we'll go
into it yeah well first let me shut this
window i mean uh channing frye 14-year
retired vet uh one-time champion
right and 16. i think for me um i
learned early on i wasn't gonna have
success being anybody else
um you know my parents always taught me
to appreciate things for what they are
uh i think the best thing that now you
talk about
nba players are pro athletes why they
struggle is because they weren't
um exposed to as many things as what we
are
when i was growing up my parents didn't
force me to just play basketball they
i was in art camp i was in band camp i
played in the band till freshman year
high school
um you know i my mother was like listen
if you bust your knee
you got to know what else you love doing
um so i was
interning at a national science museum
like i wanted to be a
marine biologist so i think these
players now are exposed to
10 000 more things where they go yes i
love basketball and this is my job
but as like there are pods to who i am
and so for me now after basketball
as a player um i love showing the game
on a lighter side uh so usually during a
regular non-covered year i have my show
handles
is on wednesday on nba tv um and then
thursday i do game time before the
the big show on tnt and then on fridays
i do road trip and podcast
or i do my nbc northwest podcast and
then
this year and almost like ever since
i've been in the league almost
i've really been into wine right and
i've seen your journey and
um i've seen a lot of journeys here but
i live in oregon and so i've been
exposed to the valley here and seeing it
grow
i'm seeing the evolution and seeing the
new kind of wave of people
and uh my friends two friends of mine
actually got together now it's three
and you know the third one uh we got
together and said how can we do this
different
and for us it's not about competition
because nobody drinks the same bottle of
wine every night
right so at chosen family the name of
our thing is we're trying to expose
people to not only new wines but amazing
wine makers
because you could have the best grapes
in the world but if the wine maker isn't
cool you don't want to
you're not going to spend your time or
your money there like it just it's not
exactly right i always i always told
people about wine makers i'm like look
you could give me the best ingredients
in the world the best foie gras caviar
wigal beef like all the decadent stuff
or clean
ingredient whatever the best you could
then give
the best chef in the world seed and d
level versions of all that and it's not
even gonna be close to what's more
delicious
so true so true you know it's funny i
used to think about
winemaking like coaching and maybe you
can make this parallel
i i believe that it is fascinating i
mean tips is doing it with the knicks at
some level
you know like like you know it's amazing
how much a wine maker matters and how
much people don't pay attention to that
and it's i'm glad to hear you say that
no no it's all about the winemaker so
the chosen family we have right now uh
we have one out we sold out of our first
three we're starting to come back with
more
we always put the label of where our
wine is from or who makes it their label
on our bottle
to say thank you for them and it's
always a relationship and it's not me
saying i'm a winemaker i'm not
so like pushing yeah i'm like you're the
character yeah i'm like thank you for
being you like i appreciate you i'm a
fan and i think it's helped us
so far we're almost a year in we're
doing pretty well um and so just going
down to wine game with basketball has
been pretty interesting and then
um dude just like you said just
investing in things
that i'm excited to learn more about
that i've dabbled in
uh like partial ownership and cards we
talked about that i'm a partial owner of
dibs
uh one of my best friends uh jesse craig
works at uh
pwc he's the man right we've had many of
open of what he's the man
um and then getting into a little bit of
bitcoin and
a little bit of uh dag and constellation
and those kind of things and so
you know there's a lot on my plate but
i'm excited to be
the rookie at a lot of it and excited to
come in with a good attitude
and i think a lot of people that whether
it's wine basketball
you know cryptocurrencies i think people
need to come in
being humble and just listen and find
what vibes with you and then go
you know go and attack it so um i just
been trying to attack life i have all
the options to do what i want now
outside of basketball and um and this
year has been pretty awesome with
basketball and his stories
and you were talking about tibs it's
tim's
is a specific coach for a specific type
of player
i think that's right in a coach whether
that's monty williams and phoenix
whether that's
you know phil jackson with jordan
whether that's whoever
terry stops with david stodemeyer when
the communication is there and when the
understanding um of backgrounds and
respect
is there you're going to get great
culture right and that goes from
wine to business to everything else when
the people who are
telling the person what to do if there's
no communication back and forth
then the story gets lost and then people
are just doing it without emotion
and so i love seeing these teams like
the hawks
the hawks i was talking about how booboo
they are for how talented they are
right if they weren't talented i would
never talk about them but
trey young is amazing john collins is
amazing uh boggy bogey is amazing you
know
galinari is good but it took one coach
to talk to them in a different way
for them to be fifth in the east they
were like
second to last last year and look at the
next it took one coach
and a change of culture for that team
who averages
the second lowest in the nba to be
fourth
and i think has a great chance to go to
the second round of playoffs
is wild and i think more people have to
see those stories
instead of kind of the stories you see a
lot of times on like the highlight films
you need to see these
these stories of real teens uh playing
and doing good things
that's right who which veteran
brought you the most value in year one
and
in and i'm asking you this so you don't
have to be humble and which
rookie do you think you brought the most
value maybe they don't even think that
so don't
feel scared but like your own
self-assessment
that you gave in year 14 or 13 or 12
other than that i'm not going to let you
go down the path
which which which vet gave you the most
and by the way giving comes in all sorts
of
amazing different ways uh and which and
which rookie
did you feel that you were able to give
the most to so i'll start with some guys
are pretty influential
in new york it was quinton richardson
and malik rose
were my two guys and malik rose had just
come from san antonio
um malik was the man and constantly was
like
channing be a pro channing be a pro
chaining don't fall into what's going on
here
there was a lot of turmoil in the next
when i was there so to go from college
four years with coach olsen
like the name of new jersey doesn't
matter to go to new york
where you're a lottery pick but then you
have the highest paid
salaries in the nba and a coach that
doesn't like rookies
but then doesn't like the guys we have
we have the most starting lineups
just jack me up but those two guys and
quentin richardson made me appreciate
the game
he had one of the hardest years my
rookie year i think his cousin died his
brother died
and we are flying to all these funerals
for him and yet he would come
to practice whenever it was time was up
and be busting people's ass
and be focused on the game and i was
like damn man like
mentally tough like people don't
understand like
people understand grief but when you
play an emotional game like basketball
or football you're a pro athlete
you have to be so emotionally invested
in those
48 minutes it's wild
to understand what he did and the
consistency that he did
when he did it and so to this day that's
my guy and then when i went to the suns
it was grant hill
and steve nash not even close those two
guys like
g hill was the consummate pro
about how basketball should be played uh
not only fearless but with fun
as a professional um into just yours
your your subjective opinion and how
much better grant
would have been had he not had all those
injuries early on
i must be honest i think he would have
been the greatest player of all time
really swear on on everything
great you're well you're willing to go
that crazy
great ladder next to oh
grant hill after all those surgeries i
saw him
at his old age was one of the fastest
guys on our team
one of the smartest guys on our team was
locking down defenders
and the only reason he had a bad game in
game six in the western conference
finals
but that's because he got in foul
trouble and kobe just went kobe
but you would if if grant had the
opportunity because he's a great
teammate
he was positionless he was explosive
you could put him you can build a team
around him
where you could be like i want to have
be a scoring
team i want to be a defensive team i
think he could have done all that
now that opportunity is a big what if
because he had all those surgeries but
i'm saying talent-wise
he's up there with lebron and jordan and
kobe
up there with me as that's how good he
was if you watch him when he was healthy
like they'll say
he penny and tracy mcgrady
i think about a lot yeah
but think about grant had grant had more
personality though
right think about like grant was on tv
shows
grant was taking flights to go do a tv
show oh grant's
granted yeah yeah i'm i'm old enough to
remember
like from day one grant was the heir
apparent to the
face of the league and that's where it
was
wild to that he was ready to take that
that step those steps he was built for
those steps
his pedigrees intelligence um his
wherewithal of where he was in history
and his aggression on the court it
wasn't like he was it wasn't like he was
doing all this stuff and not
not barbecuing guys every single night
that's what was crazy is that he was
able to balance
and that's what's wild about when you
say who's the greatest of all time
there's only been three or four guys to
balance both right
balance who people think you are and
then what you are on the court
and mush that together and be the face
of a multi-billion dollar business
night in and night out i mean for
example lebron whether you like him or
hate him he had a crappy first half
last night and then all of a sudden he
ends up with a triple double
and a shot at the end of the game it's
just like what what
who does that steph steph's face
he knew he knew steph's face
uh what about what about who you are who
you say man i did a really good job for
that kid
i really am happy or i really love that
kid i'm glad i got those words of wisdom
it was later on in my career but i felt
like i was pretty honest with everybody
but i would say my two my two young
fellas that i think
helped and they still talk to them to
this day are jordan clarkson and larry
nance guys actually got traded for and
came back
but they were so stressed about every
game
and i'm like it's not stress you're
putting into work
you're here early early you love the
game you're trying to do right by it
right
you can't stress like you're not you're
not getting 25 points every single night
you gotta
get away with that attitude that's not
you if you get if we have four games
and you're getting paid nine to ten
million dollars a a night
if you have two games 20 or above you're
doing your job
that's the crazy thing that was a very
interesting insight you're
makes sense young players you know when
you were a
national basketball association player
yeah you have had success
at every level and
you're of the mindset i right that must
be
no no it's a tremendous tremendous call
out yeah
and i've thought about it in different
ways but i've now looking at it
it just that one struck me and i it
makes so much sense
what is that moment and i actually
believe this is the reason so many
players fail
and get out of the league quickly there
is a moment probably within your first
three seasons
you're gonna i'd love to get your
perspective where you as a man
have to make a decision and say okay
because i don't think it should be your
rookie year but maybe it is and you're
going to tell me this is why i'm asking
i'm making a statement in question form
there is some sort of moment
in those first 36 months of your mba
career if you're lucky enough to have it
where you have to realize
oh wait i'm not going to be one of the
best 15 players in this league
yeah the train stops here and i need to
be mature enough
and strategic enough to figure out what
i'm going to do with this feeling
because at every other level i was good
enough to be one of the
10 15 20. you know there's only two
rounds in the nba
draft you are one of the 50 60
70 best players at that moment
do you think that happens let's say
you're healthy no injuries
yeah is that a conversation most guys
have with themselves
in year two and year three and year one
like is it like
can it be as early as like within the
first
i feel like you have to give people a
little rope yeah yeah
but what's your thoughts on that well it
has to be everyone else's fault before
it's yours
and that's just honest truth right
because nobody
you don't you just nobody looks at
themselves like that
if you were for me it was in my third
year i got traded
from new york i was like hey i remember
we had two different
coaches we had the most starting lineups
in the nba
it was a lot of dysfunction but i loved
isaiah thomas i still talked to zeke
this day i love jamal crawford
those are my guys okay so when i went to
portland i'm like
okay new chance this kid lamarcus
aldridge comes
out so i mean and i so brandon roy and
marcus aldridge were the two stars so i
said okay
nate mcmillan was good at redoing
culture like he's doing in atlanta
so lamarcus gets hurt and nate mcmillan
demarcus was obviously better than me
but i was you know
kind of ego like i could do what he's
doing in my own way
i remember he got hurt and we had
rattled off like six or eight or
something like that
and i'm like yup i got this starting job
right now
it's in my mind because i'm like well
i'm winning i'm doing what i'm supposed
to do
what lamarcus all just came back they
chanting flipped that jersey over
and i looked at him crazy he goes what
you're not starting
and at that point i realized like
okay i i'm not i'm not that dude
and that humility empowered me because
then i came to the game like
i'm gonna make this dude regret putting
me in the game
i was like if you put me in the game
you're gonna have to keep me in the game
and at the end of the day i learned from
some really good vets
there are four types of players in nba
there's a star
there's a talent there's a skill guys
and there's culture guys
right that's it right it's hard to be a
star
right if you're a skilled guy or a
specialist like i was
you'll always have a place until the
game evolves where the game is
like last night drummond can't play
right because of
how you know i saw the warriors
basically killed the big men
until you have mvp level big men right
they they were basically a dinosaur and
then they evolved into your kitchen
embiid
which is nasty for the rest of the
league joking embiid
booch and sabonis are the are the
end-all be-alls of bigs
and then anthony davis but because
because it's evolution right
there because the 13-year-old right now
who's a big is watching and he's like oh
i've got to do this it's just
it's the best it's the best i i love
watching
sports evolve yeah and the warriors did
it because they were like
okay so lebron was the beginning of one
evolution or the end of an evolution so
it's like
paul pierce tracy mcgrady kobe so you're
like
how do i get a hybrid magic johnson
jordan tracy mcgrady baby and there's
lebron
right and then everyone's like well i
can't be lebron
so all of a sudden steph curry and the
warriors anybody
quote-unquote can look at steph steph is
a
elite skilled player
right think about what steph does he
runs around you can practice running
and he shoots you can practice shooting
you cannot practice
being lebron you can't practice being
six nine
seventy that's that's why steph is so
popular so
popular it's amazing my little guy
thinks he's going to be steph yeah of
course he does he's related and
he's just so relatable even i'm i'm 45
and i'm like maybe i should be steph
like i'm gonna go shoot half court for a
year and see if i can
get a 10-day contract but you can't yeah
but that but
it feels so much more achievable than
being a
six i mean lebron is an
unprecedented athlete unbelievable
unbelievable or like you're not you
don't need to be seven foot to be
dominant in the nba right and that's
really it
but then you have these european big men
right now and name the five best bigs in
the in the
nba and all five of them are not from
america
yeah that's right joe kitch right jokic
yeah embiid
sabonis uh booch
and you can and nurkic from
right and they've evolved the game and
think about mark gasol
think about dirk so it's a positionless
game
that it had to be positionless because
the warriors had taken away the big man
oh you want to play a traditional big
man
well guess what i have a defensive
player of the year that knows that
and even if you want to force feed the
big man my threes with the two best
shooters in the history of the nba
are going to outdo your twos a hundred
thousand percent
it's numbers game and it's wild but all
of a sudden you go guess what
now i got a big man that runs my offense
and now i have four guys who are
wired to score 40 a night like denver is
with jamal murray
jenny what's interesting about this
conversation to bring it you know for
the people that are listening about us
are not as nerdy about basketball as i
am and enjoying the living [ __ ] out of
this
it's actually how i navigate as a
businessman right right
so much of my success is oh this is what
it is
oh look what's look what the opportunity
of the world presents
right i'm gonna go do this yeah yeah
right
like i oh this nft
infrastructure is now mature i'm going
to take
this intellectual property idea i've had
for a long time this super
business conference idea i've had for
i'm going to package it in this
i'm going to outflank i'm going to do
like i
literally i literally businessman like
an athlete
as a matter of fact actually don't worry
here's one for you you know what i think
nobody talks about
i genuinely like most of my competitors
yeah meanwhile
i want to put them all out of business
why because i think of business like
sport
yeah i will go ham as much as i can day
to day
but unlike sports when the buzzer hits
triple zero and you can go over and be
like hey how's sarah how are the kids
hey i saw you posted a thing about your
charity i want to write a check
yeah that's acceptable that's culture in
business
it it it's not like sport you can't
separate it so i see some of my
competitors at
conferences and they want to fight and
i'm like no no that's just business
let's be friends we
like the world's abundant i've always
admired now as a fan i hate it
yeah as a fan yeah when the jets are the
knicks lose and then i watch
my guys go give daps the other team like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that guy they're trying
to get traded nobody trying to play for
the jets
you know i get very hurt but i
understand it because in real life
in real life in business i
can compete with somebody and if they
are better and are more successful i
give them daps
and i don't think it's personal thoughts
on
transitioning to the business world yeah
and for me
i am learning very much
i can separate business and friendships
and business so when i talk to people
about business especially
if i'm getting ready to go into some
business with them
it's easy for me i could be your friend
and not want to be your teammate
or work with you and then i could be
your business partner but not be your
friend
right because of what i need to succeed
at each thing
i know how to separate that i've had
guys who are some of my good friends
who are absolutely [ __ ] hated as
teammates
because i just i just don't like how you
approach the game but i like you as a
person
so for me as business especially in the
wine industry
when you come out with a delicious wine
i'm going to go support that
and i'm going to say i'm going to
challenge us as a business
how do we do us better than they're
doing them because
that's at the end of the day how do you
do you
better right because then it's going to
translate it's going to vibrate more
with who you're dealing with and then
for me
i'm not afraid of ruffling some feathers
as long as within you know thieves rules
right you know i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to be dirty or do
anything
but i am trying to win i am trying to be
successful so
like i work a lot right i work a lot and
my wife's like dude jenny you're retired
i go
i'm very much retired and this is
awesome but this gets me going like when
i'm on a treadmill working out i love it
i'm thinking about what do we need to do
do we need more content how do we tell
our story
like what do i need to do like how can i
be better at telling
basketball do i need to explain it more
do i need to explain
like these are what i think about all
the time right i i believe it i also
think you're tenacious you know
i'm going to give you a huge shout out i
have incredible
intent but i'm also drowning yeah i have
so much going on
yeah there's definitely for sure there
is absolutely
a chance that this podcast would have
not happened yeah
i'm i'm always trying my admins big
shout out to alexandria and lou
they're they're drinking out of a fire
hose there is absolute times where
very casually on another podcast i'm
like hey you should be on the show
and then that person tries yeah we
schedule it but then i have an emergency
it gets rescheduled i literally as you
were just talking
what went through my head was
this man made sure this podcast happened
because he wants the exposure
for his brand for himself i was pumped
because i'm thrilled i'm here right now
but i also know it made me think of all
the people that
tried once it got rescheduled it didn't
get booked and they just let it go
yeah and it wasn't because i didn't want
to it's because
it in life it's just the way it is it's
kind of like
back to basketball like like i was
always i love playing pickup basketball
and i'm not good but i'm not atrocious
and the reason i'm not atrocious is
there's a couple things that are real
which is like
number one effort on defense is
fascinating and as i got older
yeah it was also a good way for me to
build up cardio
yeah yeah you know my big thing is like
i've got two torn meniscuses
i always say what's the roi of a
basketball people was like what's the
roi of social media gary i'm like before
i answer that
what's the roi of a basketball for
lebron it's gonna be billions
for me about negative four thousand
because i have two tournaments
you know like um two pounds of sweat
what i loved about basketball was in
grub pickup
life yeah yeah which is what i live in
if you just
gave a [ __ ] oh man and you played and
you played d
for real a lot of good [ __ ] can happen
when
you're playing grub ball down there in
the dddd leagues right
and and i and i but it played in the
pros too
yeah i am fascinated watching guys
in the league rack up a seven eight year
career
on tenacity and defense
basketball is the most subconscious game
anybody can play
you have a split second decision are you
going to step in front of this guy
and sacrifice yourself or not are you
thinking about what happened to play
before because you want to score 24
are you doing what's best for your team
are you setting yourself up to be
successful like for me
i wasn't the greatest defender in the
world but if i needed to be at the
middle of the paint
for a second i was gonna be there so
that my teammates could trust me right
and coach
before he passed away his only thing was
do your job when i was a freshman
uh we were playing with other freshmen
it was five of us and i was like coach
would you check me out
chen you weren't there well coach he did
this and he literally grabbed my jersey
and i said he was like dude what did i
tell you didn't say dude but he was like
channing what did i tell you yeah do
your
job i don't care if he didn't do it he
didn't do it he didn't do it
do yours and everyone will trust you
behind that and so my attitude going to
the league was
what is my job what is my assignment how
do i prepare to be successful
and then at the end of the day the game
is 10 of actually the work that i'm
doing
like the game is 48 minutes nobody
averages 48 minutes a night
the most guys play is like 38 so really
i'm working
six to 12 hours for 15 to 20 minutes
that you see
and i gotta build on that and so that's
the kind of attitude that like i take
about
any entrepreneurship that i want to get
into or anything i invest in is
what is my job here how can i do my job
where you can trust me
with more and then i can grow that way i
don't need to do your job and you don't
need to do mine
but especially on defense if i could
trust you that if i'm where i'm supposed
to be
you're where you're supposed to be good
things will happen right
think about for instance that last play
right
where they run this it's called the
memphis play it's a
everyone runs it steph was supposed to
catch the ball at the top right
who was right there anthony davis why
because he was in the right spot all he
was
was in the right spot he knows the play
he did his work
and he won the game by just being he
didn't
not trust his teammates he didn't just
go
well this guy got beat because actually
somebody else was open he goes i'm
supposed to be here
i'm going to be here and something good
happened you got to trust
being in the right spot is gonna pay off
more times than not
and a lot of people have too much other
stuff they're worried about
instead of the game and that's why i
like playoffs because if people put the
scope on
and there is nothing more important than
the now
in the playoffs where during the regular
season people are trying to win
personal awards and that's why some guys
don't get the credit that they should
because players can feel that players
know when you're padding stats to get
these individual awards
to get bonuses and not to win games
channing final thoughts as somebody
as somebody goes back and decides to
re-listen to this very thoughtful
podcast a second time
i want them to pop a nice bottle of your
wine tell everybody where
tell everybody where they can get it
well there's only one place you can get
it we are 100 dtc right now so you can
get it chosenfamilywines.com
you can follow us at chosen family wines
on instagram or you can follow me
channing fry
uh there's only four of us four partners
um we're gonna show you guys give a
shout out to them
well jay gray is one of them chase
renton who's the uh
a winemaker at longalow estate which is
delicious juice
and uh the last one is the secret which
i can't tell for a while but
it's one of uh one of gary's guys out
there in nyc now
um so it'll be interesting we're gonna
be out there pretty soon and
just try it out man give us a try you'll
you'll be there at the beginning
how we go through this process and um
listen we have so many different wines
coming out it's not like it's just pinot
noir
we have chardonnay rose we have syrah
from uh walla walla we have sonoma coast
pinot noir
we have a different type of rose we have
bubbles in two years
we have cab in two years so come on this
journey um
and just really be like get excited with
us right because we're gonna introduce
you to everything
well jenny i think you've made a lot of
fans i know i appreciate that man thank
you
fantastic thanks for being on your man
of course of course youtube watcher
what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you